(techno music)
- Super pumped to be here.
Thank you so, so much.
Been giving a lot of thought
about what I wanted
to talk about today.
I'm super excited
about the Q-and-A.
And so with the 20 minutes I
want to focus on random things
that are running through my
mind that I think could possibly
bring value to the audience.
So let's start with
number 1 up there.
I've started articulating 20
years into my career what I've
actually been up to.
Like how did I
get to this point?
I think in a world right now
where so many people want to
start talking about what they're
gonna do or who they're gonna be
or in a world where everybody
is so focused on on building
their personal brand.
And I'm clearly an advocate of
that and have had the benefits
but I want to tell Amsterdam
right now that I think an
important part of my narrative
was for the first 15 years of my
business career, I didn't say
a fucking word to anybody.
I went out and I worked 18 hours
a day and I built a liquor store
into one of the first e-commerce
wine businesses in the U.S.
and then in my mid-30s I decided
that I earned the right for the
pleasure I have right now
which is standing here.
And I think one thing that I
implore all of you to give a lot
of thought to is we now live in
a 24/7 content-driven Snapchat,
Instagram build your personal
brand world it is massively
important to have something to
talk about that is authentic and
not posturing and peacocking
to where you're going.
Look, we are living
through a very interesting time.
We are living through a time
where over the last five to
seven years we've had an
enormous growth of people that
are entrepreneurs.
Everybody's got an idea
right now in the marketplace.
And every idea that's the Uber
for sneakers is getting funded.
And what's really interesting to
me is about to go into a period.
By show of hands, how many
people in here are start-ups?
Raise your hands.
Cool. So for about 10 to 15% of
you I'm going to make a very
important recommendation
and take it for what it is.
I really do believe that the
dollars that are being pumped
into the ecosystem, if you look
at it, are starting to dry up.
And I think that we've lived
through a five to seven year
period where a lot of people
have built startups with the
main focus of
raising the next round.
What they've built is
financial arbitrage machines
not actual businesses.
So if you're one of the 20% in
this room right now I highly
recommend that you give a lot of
thought to starting converting
your start-up into an actual
business because if there's not
money your business
goes out of business.
And I think we've seen this
two or three times before and
I think we're starting to
get into that ecosystem.
So I highly,
highly recommend it.
I think the thing that is really
top of mind for me right now
that I want to drill down
here right now is
attention arbitrage.
I've been able to figure out
what I've actually been doing.
In 1996, my attention arbitrage
was actually launching an
e-commerce site
instead of opening up
a second liquor store.
I believed that the internet was
gonna be something, there's a
lot of youngsters in here but
for everybody over 40 in this
crowd you
remember this was a fad.
This was just a little thing.
People had more disrespect for
the internet than they had for
Snapchat a year ago.
So it was an interesting
period of time where
most people doubted.
My second arbitrage
was in email marketing.
In 1997, I had a 200,000
person email newsletter that
had 91.3% open rates.
How many people have done
email marketing in their career?
Those are bonkers
fucking numbers as you know.
The reason that was though was
not because I was so great or
Wine Library was so great,
it was that nobody was
email marketing.
And so I moved quickly and
believed that over the next two
to five years people would
use that medium and
that was the arbitrage.
My biggest one that built my
business was a company called
Google came out with
something called Adwords.
Most people didn't
know what it was.
I bought the word wine for five
cents a click and owned it for
9-and-a-half months
before anybody bid me up.
This is before ten
cents was the minimum.
That was obviously
a very good thing.
And on and on and on.
A lot of you became aware of
me for the first time when
YouTube first came out.
And again, in 2006 most people
weren't thinking that YouTube
was going to
become the phenomenon.
Tomorrow Casey's gonna
talk or the next day.
People are building real
businesses and brands.
This was a decade ago.
There wasn't a video on YouTube,
when I started Wine Library TV,
that had a million views yet.
Not one.
Not one video on the platform.
So it was a small platform.
Everybody thought it was stupid.
There was no advertising.
But it was the first time that
I understood that
content could drive business.
I was just, you know, as some of
you might remember I just sat in
front of a camera for
20 minutes at a time,
drinking four bottles of wine.
And hundreds of thousands
of people thought that was
interesting enough
and I was educating.
It was also the first time in my
career that I felt the effects
of what has now been the
foundation of what I've tried to
do over the last decade.
And it is probably my biggest
recommendation to
this room today.
And this is probably good
human being advice,
not just entrepreneur and
start-up and investor advice,
what I learned from Wine
Library TV is the following:
The true story of
Wine Library TV was
the day that I thought
I was going to start it
I thought I was going to
do something similar to QVC.
And I don't know if you have a
QVC or a shopping network in
Europe but QVC in
America it's a show
and they sell stuff
through the TV.
I thought I was going
to do the QVC of wine.
The first episode of that show
when that camera went on and
that light went on I realized
that this was going to be on the
internet forever.
And that I just didn't
want to peddle wine.
I decided I wanted to be a value
to people in learning about wine
because I was scared that if I
was peddling something I didn't
believe in that somebody would
come up to me at a party and
say, "Do you like this?"
And I'd say,
"No, I hate it."
They're like, "Well you fucking
said it was awesome
"on Wine Library TV.
You're a scam artist."
I'm like, "Shit, no."
So I was very focused on
leveling up and I really believe
the one great piece of advice if
you want to take anything from
this talk is we have to start
realizing that giving and doing
things in business without
expectation of return from the
other individual is probably the
greatest leverage that you could
ever deploy in your business
life though it is extremely rare
in today's business environment.
And it has absolutely been
the bedrock of what has
allowed me to win.
All my engagement.
All my selfies right over
there and signing books.
All the content.
I have nothing to sell.
I have a book that
I fucking sell once every
three years for $13.
This is not about
monetizing an audience.
It's about building leverage
to build brand versus sales.
One of the biggest things
that I see going on right now in
digital media is that we
don't have a lot of people doing
branding and marketing.
We have a lot of
people doing sales.
The reason so many of you
were confused by the value of
Snapchat is because in the
digital landscape we
now think transactional.
Everything is about what's the
ROI of every piece of content.
Every single action.
What's the last attribution?
What's the conversion rates?
It's all become math based and
that's fine because I love sales
more than anybody.
But I promise you, these fucking
guys, Nike they didn't tag me on
a browser and then re-cookie
me and then travel all over the
internet and pound me with
banner ads until I gave up
and bought it.
(laughter)
I bought it because they fucking
marketed to me over the last
20 years and I don't even
fucking know why I but it.
And that is a very
important point.
Because what we're living
through is a time where people
are just being very
transactional and conversion
based when everything
continues to get arbitraged.
Another thought that I'm curious
how many people here have gone
to the life that I've gone to?
Over the last three months, I no
longer have a laptop or an iPad.
I now only have live
through my mobile device.
How many people are on
that level doing that?
Raise your hands.
Not a lot.
And think about this conference.
I really think that this trend,
I do believe that if I came back
here in two years, that 50, 40,
30% of the hands in this room
would go up to that
following question and
I'm completely fascinated by it.
And then for everybody in the
room that is building businesses
on the internet the thought of
what's happening in your landing
page optimization or the UI/UX
of your product in a desktop
environment I think is in
the beginning stages
of being disrupted.
And that's what I really
spent most of my time in.
Which is what's the
attention arbitrage?
Where do I think your eyes and
ears are gonna be before you do
and how I go and land grab and
buy up that property and how do
I then deploy and build
the best houses on that
property through content?
That is the
pattern of my career.
In 2006, I thought this social
media thing was going to be
really big and in 2007,
2008 I laid my foundation.
And by 2007 and 8, I invested
in Facebook and Tumblr,
and Twitter and things of that nature.
And I did quite well.
I also used them to tell my
story, sell my wine,
do my thing.
I think this is super important
to understand because I think we
also decide that things
are emerging too fast.
This is not just
being first mover.
A lot of people like
to give me credit,
"You predicted all this stuff.
"You were so right."
I just want to be on the record
forever there's plenty of people
here recording,
I haven't predicted shit.
I'm not Nostradamus.
What I've done well is I've
moved quickly once
you actually started using them.
I didn't predict Twitter.
I wasn't right about Snapchat.
I was just looking at data.
Snapchat two years ago when
I first started talking about it
already had 10s of
millions of users.
There was real people using it.
I'm not predicting anything.
I'm paying attention.
There's probably very few people
in this room that are paying as
much attention to Anchor,
to Peach, to all these platforms
as I am but I'm not putting all my
content or all my time and
I'm also not crippled by putting
my time and effort into
platforms before they have
100 or 200 million users.
For example, how many of you
remember that five minutes
four years ago where
SocialCam got big?
Raise your hand.
Alright, so three nerds.
(laughter)
SocialCam got big for three
minutes because of the
Facebook News Feed juiced it and
it had a lot of users and it was
hot for four months, six months.
I used it feverishly
and used it a lot.
It collapsed and meant nothing.
But during that period, I
learned so much about mobile
video and the cadence of it and
how people interacted with it
that when Vine came along a
year and a half later and then
Instagram video
and then Snapchat.
I had already put in the work
and had the learnings from human
behavior that I deployed
against the next thing.
There are way too many people in
this room that do not do actions
because they're crippled by the
short term results versus what
it means in the long term.
And this goes to marketing,
and this goes to running your
business, and this comes down to
what I probably want to spend a
few more minutes on right now,
which is, my friends, there's a
lot of people in here that are
start-up founders that
should not be.
My friends, there are a lot
of people in here that work at
agencies that should not be.
They should be probably
switched and vice versa
and different things.
One of the things that is
absolutely driving me right now
in my life is
the untold depression,
the untold suicides,
to just get dark for a second,
it's not fun to talk about
but it's important.
We are lacking
self-awareness in this space.
In a very substantial way.
And there's a lot of people that
are about to be met with a lot
of disappointment
and are struggling.
How many people are an
entrepreneur in here?
Raise your hand.
You guys and gals know,
this isn't easy.
There's nobody else.
It's fun to work for
somebody, you know why?
You get to blame the boss.
She and he is an
asshole not you.
When you're an entrepreneur
where there's nobody else
behind you, it's on you.
And one thing we're not talking
about is the level of success.
Everybody thinks that
the build fucking Uber.
Everybody thinks they have
to make millions of dollars.
It's unbelievable
what we've done.
And I absolutely want to make
sure that we're starting to have
real conversations.
Making $100,000 a year,
€100,000 that's
massively successful.
We need to recalibrate what
success looks like in our space
because we're forcing through
the branding of what we're
doing very impractical,
very high risk, very low return
results for so many.
'Cause everybody's
shooting for 10 billion.
Guys, there's like
four apps that big.
There's like Uber and Instagram.
How many fucking billion
dollar companies do you
think there are?
And so I really am passionate
about starting to reframe the
conversation about the number
one thing that I have noticed in
my 20 years of my success
because let me tell you
something I suck shit
at almost everything.
What I've done well is I have
deployed self-awareness around
what I am and I know what I am.
There's a lot of
things that I wish I was.
Seven years ago, as a lot of you
know, I had plenty of leverage
and the web 2.0
social media movement.
I was one of the guys.
I was one of 20 most
followed people on Twitter.
I didn't go raise $40 million
to build the next Facebook.
I didn't raise $50 million to
build a platform around wine.
I was self-aware enough even
though I had all the opportunity
in the world to build
product that I wasn't
gonna be successful.
Seven years ago I went out and
built a boring digital agency.
Right?
I built something practical.
All my internet friends, a lot
of people that are going to be
on this stage,
they made fun of me.
Why don't you go build a big
company or something grand?
I built what I
knew I could build.
I'm very proud that over the
last four years I've grown
VaynerMedia from $3 to $100
million a year in revenue
not fucking valuation.
(laughter and applause)
And cool, great, that's fine and
who gives a shit what I am way
more worried about than
what I've done is what
you're gonna do.
I implore you, my friends,
this is fancy, first of all,
this is unbelievable.
This is one of the nicest
setups to a conference
I have ever seen.
Let's clap it up for these guys.
This is unbelievable.
(applause)
Right?
There's like
fucking food trucks.
It's sunny and shit.
This is fucking awesome.
(laughter)
Anyway.
What I did well was I
didn't give a shit.
I'm old. I'm 40.
When I grew up in the
United States being a
good student was the big thing.
I was making $3,000 a weekend
selling baseball cards and
getting D's and F's and
everybody thought I was a loser.
That's what the narrative was.
Now it's reversed.
If I was in school now making
three or $4000 a weekend as
a 13 year old, I would have
been the next big thing, right?
I went through it and I did
not succumb to the current thing
that everybody thought in
America which was the right
thing which was go to the
best will you could go to.
I understood who I was and I
went in all-in on my strengths.
And I implore a lot
of you to do that.
There's too many people sitting
in this room that want to be the
number one, CEO, founder
but if you were the
seventh employee of a company.
I'd would much rather be
number 41 at Facebook than
number one of Face-smuck.
(laughter)
And so, I think
we're seeing that.
I'd like to stand up here
and I'd like to say look
there's a lot of things that
I wish I was different at.
As a matter of fact,
let's be very meta-
right now, do you know that I
wish I didn't curse on stage?
Do you know how many people
don't share my content,
don't like me because of it?
I wish I didn't do it, I just
can't be anything that I am not.
So I implore you don't worry
about what's cool right now or
what we are all focused on or
what your mama wants you to be
you need to go home from this
conference you'll be inspired,
there'll be cool people,
there's interesting shit but
I'm telling you with the bottom
of my heart it is fundamentally
irrelevant if you don't
know who the fuck you are.
The quicker you can
start forcing yourself to
understanding what role you play
number one, number seven,
PR, marketing, product, UI,
everybody wants to be
somebody else.
I wish I was the quarterback
of the New York Jets.
It's not going to happen.
(laughter)
And so if I can accomplish one
and by the way I'm being very
realistic I'll be very, very
transparent with you this little
seven minute rant that
I just came up with,
I'm trying to reach one person.
This is not so easy.
It's hard to have the ego and
the humility at equal ends to
figure yourself out.
But I promise you as I have
looked across the landscape and
I have looked at 25, 50,000
start-ups at this point, right?
I have now spent the last
four years of my life
with the Toyotas and
the Pepsi's and the GE,
you know, the biggest
brands in the world,
myself, my inner circle the one
connection point from
Corporate America to start-up
to VC to personalities,
the one connection point
is self-awareness.
Once you start understanding
yourself, once you start
actually executing on who you
actually are versus who you wish
you were things start
to change very quickly.
And so the reason I'm passionate
about this is this is always
very worldly advice and is
probably historically always
good things to talk about I just
feel that if any of you really
paid attention to the
macroeconomic infrastructure of
what's happening in our space
right now this nirvana that
we've lived through for the
last six or seven years
is about to shift.
It just is.
It's just the data.
I don't want it.
I wish it was nirvana forever
just like everybody else.
During the down cycles, the
people that are able to win are
the ones that are most
in tune with themselves.
The ones that are
most practical.
So again.
To make this valuable
to you in this room.
Number one, if you're a startup
please start understanding how
you're going to make
money as soon as possible.
You're running a business.
Businesses need to make money
especially when there's no money
to fund you based on
your last valuation.
Number two, as a human being
sitting at this conference,
this is all very encompassing and
very exciting but start chipping
away against what you think you
want and start really looking at
what you bring to the table
because the quicker you figure
that out the more success
you will you will have.
And number three, please start
understanding how to provide
value without
expectation in return.
It is unbelievable to me how
many people already today I was
here for five minutes, seven,
eight people people giving me
something as they think but
really expecting something in
return for that give.
Humans can feel that.
It's not the way to go.
And we really need to
start thinking about that.
And number four, understand
the following and this is very
ironic given my concerns
about where the market is going.
I'll end with this.
In lieu of all that this whole
thing that we are living through
has just started.
The consumer web is
only 20 years old.
Windows 95 kinda
started this thing.
The internet thing is very new.
Everything that we all talk
about didn't exist 10 years ago.
Over the next 10 years the
biggest companies in the world
from Europe and Asia and US,
from anywhere in the world
because we are now at scale the
biggest companies in the world
are going to be created over
the next 20 years from zero.
There are people sitting in this
room right now that are going to
build the next major company.
And so we are all so blessed
that we are actually human
beings during this period where
there is so much upside,
so much opportunity, and so
everything I've talked about
when you parallel on the
obnoxious opportunity and
land grab and opportunity
if you're able to wire those
two things together,
I think a lot of good stuff
could happen for you and
I'd like that for you.
I'd like that a lot.
Thank you.
(applause)
(techno music)